[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález nuestro tema de
debate del día de hoy nos lleva hasta
chile este país está inmerso en una
espiral de tensión desde diferentes
frentes primero se cumplen ya dos años
del inicio del llamado estallido social
que llevó a la redacción de una nueva
constitución algo que está en un proceso
en marcha pero la atención social vuelve
a sentirse con
fuera de la ciudad de santiago en la
región de la araucanía a raíz de ese
conflicto que hay entre el estado
chileno y los mapuches que mantienen una
serie de reclamos históricos un
conflicto sin una solución a la vista
por lo menos en el corto plazo los
enfrentamientos y las manifestaciones
llevaron a la militarización de esta
zona unos días pasados estas fueron las
palabras del presidente de chile
sebastián piñera precisamente sobre este
tema escuchemos
queridos compatriotas ninguna decisión
es fácil este estatuto de excepción
constitucional de emergencia es para
enfrentar mejor con mejores instrumentos
y herramientas el terrorismo el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado que
se han realizado en esas provincias y en
esos territorios pero en ningún caso se
orienta en contra de un pueblo o de un
grupo de ciudadanos este estado de
emergencia lo hemos decretado para poder
permitir a los habitantes de las zonas
afectadas vivir con mayor paz bueno pues
esa es la versión de la presidencia de
chile la versión oficial ya veremos en
este debate la otra cara de la moneda
con nuestros invitados otro frente de
esta crisis son las acusaciones contra
el presidente piñera por la venta
irregular de la minera dominga y también
por otra minera en esta zona del norte
del país que era parte de una empresa de
sus hijos una transacción que fue
revelada en los papeles de pandora la
investigación del consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación que y resonancia a nivel
internacional este hecho ha llevado a
que sectores de la oposición acusaron
formalmente al mandatario la fiscalía
chilena también ya abrió una
investigación por cohecho y por sobornos
veamos estamos frente al peor gobierno
de la historia no solamente en términos
de corrupción aquí no hay solamente un
acto y una omisión por parte del
presidente la república esto es acción
una acción sistemática por parte de un
gobierno que ha sido incapaz de separar
los negocios personales del presidente y
de su familia del bienestar general de
la nación y del interés de sus
ciudadanos y ciudadanas y de la
protección del medio ambiente un posible
juicio político podría desembocar en una
destitución o inhabilitación de piñera
para ejercer cargos públicos en el
futuro el mandatario se ha defendido
argumentando que su vínculo con este
negocio terminó en 2009 y añadió que lo
revelado en los papeles de pandora ya
fue investigado anteriormente así se
estaba defendiendo el presidente piñera
veamos
los antecedentes de esta venta
incluyendo su precio forma de pago y
condiciones fueron conocidas por la
fiscalía por el tribunal de garantía y
por la corte de apelaciones
todos ellos determinaron en forma
consistente y unánime la inexistencia de
delitos y la inocencia de mi persona
tengo la plena confianza en que la
justicia como ya lo ha hecho
confirmará la inexistencia de
irregularidades y también mi total
inocencia
bueno pues así las cosas se trata del
segundo proceso que enfrenta sebastián
piñera luego de que noviembre de 2019
fuera acusado de supuestas violaciones
de los derechos humanos durante el
estallido social según una encuesta de
la consultora activa research el 67.7
por ciento de las personas que fueron
consultadas allí en chile- están de
acuerdo en un juicio político contra el
presidente mientras que un 14.9 por
ciento está en desacuerdo con este
procedimiento todo esto sucede también
en el marco de una campaña electoral
para las presidenciales del 21 de
noviembre ya lo vemos chile está
enfrentando múltiples en frentes de
crisis la mala ahora del presidente
sebastián piñera y la situación en este
país suramericano
tema de debate en france 24 para
profundizar en este tema saludamos a
aucán huilcamán él es líder mapuche
encargado de relaciones internacionales
del consejo de todas las tierras él se
encuentra en la ciudad de temuco esto
queda en el sur de chile también está
con nosotros sebastián álvarez diputado
de la región de la araucanía del partido
político de político evo poli también se
encuentra en la ciudad de temuco también
hay en el sur de chile y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 se encuentra con
nosotros maría teresa allá es la
ciudadana colombo chilena analista
internacional coordinadora de la
maestría de asuntos internacionales de
la universidad externado de colombia
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con sus
comentarios con todas sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como france24 bajo ese santi
logo que es mi cuenta personal el
numeral se lo recuerdo en la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios participen dejen sus
preguntas y comentarios que es muy
importante para nosotros también conocer
lo que opinan nuestros televidentes
comenzamos hablando por el tema del
conflicto con los mapuches comienzo aquí
en el estudio france24 con maria tereza
preguntándole por qué este conflicto con
los mapuches parece no tener fin y cada
cierto tiempo vuelven y se abren
pequeños
enfrentamientos entre el gobierno
central y está este grupo originario del
sur de chile esto es para explicarlo por
lo menos para las personas que están
fuera de las fronteras de chile que no
entiende cuál es este conflicto es un
conflicto histórico santiago un
conflicto que lleva 500 años desde el
descubrimiento de américa los mapuche en
la frontera sur como se llama la
frontera de temuco hacia el sur de chile
en la época de la colonia eran bastante
aguerridos y bastante fuertes en lo que
era mi territorio mi soberanía y mi
manera mi identidad en este sentido es
un conflicto histórico en los siglos 19
con la llegada sobretodo de alemanes al
país se empezó a colonizar realmente lo
que no habían hecho los españoles a
fondo esta tierra y se empezaron a
quedar grandes industrias agropecuarias
y esas empezaron a quitarle tierra a los
mapuches literalmente grandes industrias
hoy el problema es ancestral la tierra
de los ancestros es un conflicto que se
dice territorial pero que en los últimos
años en el siglo 21 ha tomado también un
matiz político un matiz bastante
político de autodeterminación más allá
de lo simple territorial y de derechos
ancestrales y este es el gran problema
que enfrenta a un presidente no muy
querido y que no le está yendo muy bien
como es el presidente piñera vamos a
complementar esta información maria
tereza con nuestros invitados
precisamente en temuco en el sur de
chile comienzo con aucán preguntándole
para complementar lo que hemos dicho
porque este conflicto
parece tener momentos de tensión de alta
tensión como lo que se está viviendo en
este momento lo que veíamos la semana
pasada allí en diferentes poblaciones de
la región
y tal parece que vuelve y entra en un
estado de
quedarse dormido y vuelve y despierta
buenas noches efectivamente es un
conflicto
de que lo origina el estado chileno
y lo original estado chileno al momento
que esta institución tomó la decisión
de ocupar militarmente el territorio
mapuche
y en lo que se conoce como pacificación
de la araucanía en donde se cometieron
tres hechos consecutivos y son las
causas de las actuales tensiones y
controversias el ejército chileno
cometió el crimen de genocidio que está
en completa impunidad y ningún gobierno
ha querido abordar en segundo lugar se
produce en la toma confiscación y
ocupación del territorio y su recurso y
en tercer lugar el daño cultural en el
ámbito material e inmaterial estas tres
cuestiones son las causas de las
actuales tensiones y controversias que
vienen desde pacificación de la
araucanía por lo tanto este no es un
problema de democracia ni de
participación sino es la manera que
llegó el estado chileno al territorio
mapuche
mediante la fuerza y la violencia
militar vulnerando todos los derechos
que le asiste al pueblo mapuche y por lo
tanto es mucho más allá que tierra como
es señalado el delito de genocidio
configurado con los actos que ha
realizado o que realizó el ejército
chileno en mil 860 al 1881 sería el día
de hoy es el punto central en el vamos
uniendo piezas a este rompecabezas
sebastián al varias también allí en la
ciudad de temuco su opinión porque este
conflicto con los mapuches
persiste no parece encontrar una
solución en el corto o mediano plazo
bueno buenas noches la verdad que como
bien lo mencionaba aucán este es un
conflicto que data de hace dos siglos
atrás es un conflicto que produjo el
estado de chile que lamentablemente hoy
este conflicto trae un inmenso
sufrimiento y dolor no solamente a los
mapuches que fueron víctimas justamente
de este genocidio de la tomé los
territorios y de la pérdida cultural
material inmaterial sino que hoy en día
este conflicto genera desesperanza en
más de 900 mil habitantes
chilenos
extranjeros y gente que sabe sentado en
estas zonas y que hoy en día sufren
producto de la violencia desatada que
está por sobre todo el territorio y como
bien se indica este conflicto requiere
diálogo requiere acuerdos políticos
respecto al reconocimiento de la cultura
indígena
respecto al reconocimiento
constitucional de los pueblos indígenas
en nuestro país y en el desarrollo de
las comunidades en el sentido de
progresión de agua camino electricidad
desarrollo en fin muchos factores que
sebastián en una u otra forma el estado
de chile ha buscado reparar pero que
hasta este momento no dijo la
disponibilidad de dialogar y de
concordar un camino que permita
pacificar lo que hoy en día tiene
lamentablemente
sufriendo y generando víctimas
en el territorio aunque han sigo con
usted en allí en temuco preguntándole
sobre esta reacción que tuvo el
presidente sebastián piñera de
militarizar esta zona y declarar el
estado de excepción
cree usted que fue una reacción
exagerada por parte del mandatario como
lo vio usted
por un lado completamente exagerada y en
otro lo hace coincidir con un 12 de
octubre y el 12 de octubre es una fecha
trágica para los pueblos indígenas de
mente creo que es simbólicamente la peor
decisión que toma un jefe de estado pero
desde el punto de vista de la situación
en que se encuentra el presidente de la
república él está como ha dicho el
reporte entre situación muy compleja él
está involucrado en hechos reprochable
que poco jefe de estado ha tenido en
chile en segundo lugar está acusado
constitucionalmente y hay una
investigación del ministerio público y
está en la calidad de imputado por lo
tanto esta es una estrategia
comunicacional del gobierno
a admitir su responsabilidad y trasladar
una problemática historia histórica que
es tan grave y tan seria entonces
militarizando la región de araucanía
adoptando un estado de excepción que hoy
día está operando en la región
sebastián citando textualmente al
presidente piñera él ha dicho que ha
declarado este estado de excepción como
una herramienta contra el terrorismo el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado que
se puede decir de esos tres argumentos
es una región donde hay posibilidades o
amenazas de terroristas de terrorismo
hay allí amenaza del narcotráfico del
narcotráfico de grupos del narcotráfico
internacional que nos dice usted es
importante hacer las distinciones
hay un tema histórico
político pero hoy en día hay un tema que
no tiene relación con el territorio como
político sino que tiene que ver
precisamente con una política criminal
terrorista
que operan grupos de narcotraficantes
bajo mi expresión muchas veces
escondidos tras la causa del conflicto
histórico mapuche y esto atraigo yo lo
decía muertes asesinatos crímenes de
civiles de personas inocentes aquí se ha
afectado a familias a personas que con
mucho esfuerzo han forjado
emprendimiento trabajo y que hoy en día
se ven afectados por ejemplo hace muy
poquito se quema una terna de una
familia sencilla trabajadora un proyecto
de vida es incendiada completamente hoy
día hubo cinco atentados terroristas en
la región hoy en día la ciudadanía tiene
susto tiene temor de transitar de
circular por las vías de la araucanía
esto está trayendo un perjuicio muy
grande a la comunidad el aspecto
psicológico de moral se gran
desmoralizando el tejido productivo de
la región esto está trayendo pobreza
esto está trayendo desamparo a la región
más pobre de chile por eso este estado
de emergencia viene justamente a poder
resguardar la acción de los hijos
armados porque cuando se dice que se
militariza la araucanía quiero decirle
que esta región está militarizada desde
el momento que grupos armados
comienzan a operar de 6 se va a la
cristina haciendo realizando acciones
médicas vamos a analizar la situación en
maria tereza aquí en el estudio de
france 24 como analizar estos argumentos
del presidente chileno en el contexto en
el que está el previo a estas elecciones
presidenciales en las cuales no
participa pero pues es el cierre de su
mandato y lo que dicen nuestros
invitados sobre la situación que se está
viviendo allí y estos argumentos del
mandatario aquí hay que tener claro que
cuando él ordena la militarización de la
zona mapuche de la araucanía
habían pasado cuatro días desde que
salieron a la luz los famosos pantoja
papers en donde lo acusan a él de no
actuar con probidad y transparencia
diríamos nosotros dos para muchos fue un
sofisma de distracción
yo qué puedo hacer como distraigo la
gente la actitud de la gente con una
causa que yo creo que él pensó dijo esto
me va a generar alguno que otro rédito
porque como bien lo han dicho es una
zona que se ha convertido en mucha
violencia en las que más yo recuerdo el
caso luck singer en el 2013 cuando
queman esta casa con la gente adentro
con la pareja dentro él la quema de
iglesias de cementerios en el año 2016
es decir las pocas las acciones de unos
pocos realmente han hecho que la gente
diga a que hay que actuar hay que actuar
con mano dura no podemos dejar que esto
se salga de control y el presidente
piñera dice a lo mejor por matar dos
pájaros con un tiro el tema de que puedo
ser suave por no ser suave que en
momentos en que estamos hablando de una
constitución que va a incluir las
garantías y los derechos para los
pueblos originarios en chile pues tal
vez sí o no pero el trato de matar dos
pájaros de un tiro' yo creo el trato de
decir distraigo la atención me voy con
una causa que puede generar menos que
otro rédito
y miro a ver qué pasa aunque allí en la
ciudad de temuco para poner en contexto
a la audiencia que está fuera de chile
ustedes mencionan que la araucanía es la
región más pobre de chile pero para
américa latina chile siempre va a ser un
referente en cuanto a desarrollo y a
crecimiento económico es presente el
estado chileno allí en esta región
ustedes sienten que falta más presencia
con relación a otras regiones si se
compara con otros sectores del país como
es la presencia del estado chileno allí
la presencia del estado chileno en el
territorio mapuche
eres casi completamente
militarizada
[Música]
y prácticamente hay que tener en cuenta
que la región de la araucanía a los
mapuches lo empobrecieron porque le
despojaron de su territorio en
definitiva hoy día los políticos juegan
con el concepto de pobreza de la región
sin embargo hay que subrayar que al foro
mapuche lo empobrecieron económicamente
a raíz del despojo de tierra en ese
sentido hay que tener en cuenta
que la región de araucanía dispone de
recursos únicos y de gran de mucho valor
que no podría estar en estas condiciones
el problema es que la relación injusta
en la tenencia de la tierra en la
distribución en la participación de los
pueblos indígenas en su destino y en el
caso los mapuches en la causa principal
de este conflicto que permanece de
manera constante porque en definitiva
los mapuches cada vez tienen más
conciencia y el estado chileno se
instaló en el territorio mediante la
fuerza y la violencia y que los
gobiernos han hecho un esfuerzo para
colombianizar la araucanía para así
justificar sus actos en definitiva los
políticos han usado la de ucrania para
su propio fin y hay que recordar que el
propio presidente sebastián piñera envió
una unidad militar y acá de carabinero
para prepararse en colombia se llevaron
29 camiones en donde participó a toda la
institucionalidad del estado en
definitiva la práctica de la de colombia
de los actos irregulares de la violencia
sin límites se está trasladando la
araucanía pero no lo no solamente lo
hizo este gobierno sino también lo hizo
el gobierno de la presidenta michelle
bachelet y que en la causa de las
actuales tensiones y controversias
sebastián ustedes están en prácticamente
ya la recta final de unas elecciones
presidenciales que están siendo muy
controvertidas por el escenario político
que se está presentando en chile como
ven ustedes el tema del conflicto de los
mapuches en los debates que han tenido
los candidatos en los programas de
gobierno de los candidatos hay un buen
despliegue se está tomando en cuenta o
esto va a volver a quedar por fuera como
queda como a la luz en los gobiernos
recientes
aquí lo dije en un principio hace falta
la decisión de todas las partes de
sentarse a parlamentar a dialogar a
establecer acuerdos políticos que nos
permitan avanzar
lamentablemente veo que no existe una
real conciencia conocimiento por parte
de los candidatos respecto a la
situación de la araucanía muchos vienen
acá y hace un poco lo que se llama el
turismo político vienen opina dan cuenta
de algunas soluciones sin tener en claro
el conocimiento acá la clave es sentarse
a dialogar hacer un acuerdo de paz real
el entender que podemos convivir en esta
tierra que presenta muchas oportunidades
de desarrollo para todos por igual y
entender que es un conflicto histórico
que lamentablemente hoy genera mucho
daño a muchas personas que no tienen
ningún tipo de responsabilidad el
habitante actual no tiene ninguna
responsabilidad de lo sucedido y
realizado por el estado de chile hace
años atrás por lo tanto vivía
lamentablemente
veo mucha claridad con respecto al
camino a seguir para el tema del
conflicto a la araucanía
aunque para ir cerrando ya este tema
para avanzar con otros temas de la
agenda
desde julio está en negociaciones a
redacción de la nueva constitución que
es lo que ha dejado el estallido social
el gran reclamo que tenían los
ciudadanos chilenos hay 17
representantes indígenas entre ellos en
la líder que está al mando de todo esto
es una ciudadana mapuche ven ustedes
esto con buenos ojos como que esto les
va a permitir por fin darle al pueblo
mapuche el lugar que se merece el lugar
que históricamente ha tenido para chile
no hay certeza que efectivamente va a
ocurrir un cambio de relación de alta
significación entre el estado chileno y
el pueblo mapuche porque hay que tener
en cuenta que
los pueblos indígenas en américa latina
y el caribe llevan participando de
nuevas constituciones y de reformas
constitucionales durante 50 años y no se
ha mejorado la relación de un estado y
pueblo indígena de la misma manera
entonces aquí esto es un hecho incierto
en ese orden el derecho internacional ha
establecido el derecho de
autodeterminación de los pueblos
indígenas y aquí hay organizaciones
mapuches que están trabajando hacia la
conformación de un gobierno de manera
separada ese proceso constituyente del
pueblo chileno porque es un proceso
constituyente del pueblo chileno luego
el estallido social y los mapuches son y
somos titulares del derecho libre
determinación al amparo del derecho
internacional por lo tanto
y teniendo en cuenta esa situación aquí
hay dos procesos en chile- uno lo que
tiene el pueblo chileno y el otro los
mapuches hacia la conformación de un
gobierno porque el derecho de
autodeterminación es un derecho cierto y
depende de la capacidad y la voluntad de
los propios mapuche y a partir de ese
gobierno mapuche establecer las
relaciones que son aceptables una
relación de convivencia pacífica sería
en el estado chileno y el pueblo mapuche
para theresa cómo entender esta pieza
del rompecabezas el derecho de
autodeterminación que tiene el pueblo
chileno en dado caso es viable esto en
un país como chile y viendo el contexto
en el que están que prácticamente los
candidatos presidenciales pues tienen
este tema como secundario que la
constitución no se sabe si les va a dar
la importancia que merecen puede haber
ahí una especie de referente
independencia un estado mapuche
independiente
este estado mapuche cortaría chile en
dos ya tendríamos un problema soberanía
entre la franja de la araucanía para
después volver a puntarenas en el más
alto todavía magallanes eso sería
bastante complicado para el estado
chileno yo creo que el estado chileno se
ha ayudando cuenta muy tardíamente pero
lentamente de la necesidad de hablar con
los mapuches recordemos que la
presidente bachelet en su momento le
pidió perdón al pueblo mapuche por todo
lo acaecido y lo que era culpa del
gobierno chileno a lo largo de su
historia unos decían que le habló al
pueblo mapuche pero que realmente quería
era que la oyera la comunidad
internacional no importa pidió perdón y
yo creo que esos son los puntos de
origen que uno tiene que utilizar para
un chile unido son dos proyectos
políticos distintos pero dentro de un
solo país y yo creo que la constitución
va a tomar esto en cuenta las elecciones
tal vez no hoy la política me gustó la
frase de turismo político pero yo sí
creo que la constitución tiene que tomar
en cuenta y no sólo los mapuches los
haimar en el norte los rapanui en isla
de pascua son temas que tienen que ir en
la constitución integrados en un solo
país que es chile como país y santiago
quisiera decir uno habla de
colombianización con los mapuches en el
norte cerca de arica uno habla de
colombianización en valparaíso las que
quieren hablar de este micro tráfico de
personas de drogas y de terrorismo en el
país yo creo que deberíamos salirnos de
eso concentrarnos en los problemas
realmente originarios porque nuevamente
si le damos
razón a todos estos micro temas nos
desviamos de la petición de
autodeterminación que debería ser lo
importante en este momento que es una de
las piezas claves de esta agenda cierro
este tema sé que quedan muchas cosas por
conversar pero debo avanzar en otros de
los temas que tenemos para este programa
y es la situación en la que se encuentra
el presidente sebastián piñera maría
tereza después de salir a la luz los
papeles de pandora que le ha dado una
visibilidad a nivel internacional por
este tema de la venta de la mina
dominga que pertenecía a un grupo que al
parecer sus hijos están allí eso
supuestamente ya está todo aclarado dice
lo veíamos anteriormente pero esto le ha
generado muchísimos problemas a nivel
local esto cierra su gobierno de una
manera muy negativa como lo que usted yo
creo que nunca tuvo una aprobación
grande y menos en este segundo gobierno
de él él sostiene y todo se va a reducir
a qué pasó en el año 2017 en el 2017
hicieron un juicio una primera mirada a
los intereses de piñera la familia
piñera es supremamente rica y tiene
muchos intereses comerciales en todo el
país y en otros lugares de sudamérica
recordemos que era socio mayoritario de
lan antes de ser latam es decir tiene
muchos negocios y cuando llega a su
primera presidencia del general lo que
él llama los fideicomisos ciegos yo no
me meto ustedes hagan y manejen lo que
quieran en el 2017 cierra un primer
proceso que lo acusaba precisamente
ahora tiene unos problemas con una
pesquera en donde es hablo del fallo de
la haya que si tenía uno intereses la
pesquera el fallo la haya la zona de
pesca artesanal pesca industrial
sostiene piñera y sus abogados que en
este caso miraron el tema la dominga y
todo quedó saldado cuando hicieron en el
2017 aquí no pasó nada quienes lo acusan
y es interesante que se unen desde los
demócratas cristianos hasta los
comunistas en esta acusación
sostienen que eso fue una arista del
mayo del 2017 y que realmente nos
investigó y por eso ahora hay que
investigarla el presente piñera no va a
salir con mucha aprobación y no va a
salir siendo muy querido por el pueblo
chileno si así cierra o puede que sea el
cierre de su gobierno sebastián le
pregunto por este tema sobre esa
posibilidad de llevar al presidente
piñera a un juicio político ya pocos
meses de terminar su segundo mandato ir
a un juicio el presidente piñera como lo
vio usted
a él lo primero hay que decir de forma
clara el chile existen los poderes
independientes el poder ejecutivo
legislativo y judicial por lo tanto lo
está acusación constitucional es
precisamente como usted bien lo ha dicho
es un juicio político es un juicio
político por parte de la oposición hacia
el mandatario pero son los tribunales de
justicia
quienes tienen que revisar esta causa y
en el caso que haya habido una acción
dolosa en el proceder del actual
presidente de nuestro país esto creo que
tiene que tener justicia que es lo que
todo lo que pide sensible que exista
justicia pero distingamos por favor lo
que es un juicio político que es lo que
puede hacer el congreso y lo que pueda
determinar los tribunales de justicia yo
no soy pues no pertenezco al poder
judicial para poder determinar la
responsabilidad o no del presidente en
lo que se le acusa sin embargo creo que
un juicio político a seis meses de
terminar su mandato creo que pueden
hacer un daño mayor al clima de
conflicto que hoy existe en nuestro país
y aunque no usted como líder de una
región y de una digámoslo minoría si se
le puede llamar así en esta en este país
suramericano
como ve usted la situación del
presidente tendrá curso esto en el
congreso a pocos meses de terminar la
este mandato este segundo mandato del
presidente piñera
hasta el momento hemos visto que
prevalece la impunidad por la clase
política chilena
no hay esa autonomía e imparcialidad de
los poderes por tanto desde mi deseo y
de lo que debiera ser verdaderamente
aceptable que debiera
ponerse fin a la impunidad de la clase
política chilena hay que recordar que la
población chilena no le tiene
credibilidad a la clase política por sus
actos
contraria a la a los principios
éticos de toda clase política por tanto
él lo que sucede allí en la acusación
constitucional es un paso y esperamos
que esto tenga una sanción final maría
tereza que tan rodeado está el
presidente piñera en este momento que
tan rodeado y acompañado está en la
moneda en este momento de cierre de su
gobierno con todas estas crisis abiertas
él tiene sus amigos tiene suministros
que lo están apoyando el más en algún
momento se dijo que él tenía que
defenderse solo y no utilizar al
gobierno o su gabinete para defenderse
pero más allá de eso es un presidente
que está muy solo tiene una popularidad
muy muy baja menos de un 20 por ciento
en el país y es un presidente aquí hay
que decirlo es un presidente que no
llegó siendo muy querido y con una gran
carisma llegó más bien por un voto en
contra a un
socialismo que se unió con la beatriz
antes y con el partido comunista y fue
más bien un voto en contra esta
coalición que un voto a favor de piñera
y eso se ha visto en estos cuatro años y
yo creo que la tiene un gobierno muy
duro y yo creo que sí va a terminar con
baja popularidad y esperemos por el bien
de chile como lo decidan que esto sea
algo que sea de impunidad de que nuestra
impunidad y que no se convierta en algo
político porque está muy solo vamos ya
para el cierre del programa me queda un
minuto sebastián conclusiones qué va a
pasar en su país en los próximos meses
en términos políticos
chile enfrenta un escenario de mucha
incertidumbre de mucho conflicto social
y también de mucha violencia es de
esperar que la ciudadanía 'el a pocos
meses la elección pueda tomar una buena
decisión y que pueda optar por aquel que
pueda ofrecer un proyecto de paz un
proyecto unidad de desarrollo que nos
permita volver a ser ese país como usted
bien lo decía ejemplo para latinoamérica
y el mundo del progreso de unidad y de
trabajo comunitario por el desarrollo de
todos sus habitantes
aucán su conclusión que viene para su
país
tal cual están las cosas no veo que haya
un va a suceder un cambio significativo
debido a que hay una gran disconformidad
en el país y no se observa en un
compromiso del futuro gobierno o de los
futuros candidatos que están discutiendo
aquí lo que va a suceder al araucanía
por lo tanto esto pone en un escenario
completamente incierto sobre la ok
entonces hay que asumir la
responsabilidad de empujar para que esto
sea mejor maria tereza rápidamente 10
segundos para el cierre conclusión chile
tiene elecciones en 4 semanas yo creo
que hay que mantener un chile unido una
constituyente que empezó hoy a debatir
grandes temas y yo creo que chile tiene
como irle muy bien en este siglo la
maria teresa sebastián aunque les
agradezco haber estado con nosotros aquí
en el programa haber expresado aquí
abiertamente sus opiniones sobre este
tema ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios en las redes sociales sigan
con nosotros
[Música]